yes Kimmy Schmidt is back with an
interactive Netflix special and get this
Kimmy is marrying a British Prince
played by none other than Harry Potter
himself Daniel Radcliffe
you certainly poked a little bit of fun
at like the the way that Royals might
grow up I don't think I have any like
worries about it I feel like the royal
family and you know busy enough without
having to worry about what impression
I'm leaving of them on on a Netflix
special the cool thing about the
unbreakable kimmy schmitt interactive
special the viewer gets to decide how
the story plays out there is so much be
done before our wedding like practicing
for our honeymoon oh boy I do like
kissing you and are you I think some
scenes we shot four different versions
of depending on how you got to it do you
have any idea how many outcomes there
are and how long did it take to film it
all I wanna say was 22 days which is
crazy that's silly less time in this
lockdown they're making me Cammie
another girl girls world
God Richard shut up John ham returns as
the Reverend James Krakowski is back as
an agent but Carol Kane has the scene
that took everyone by surprise
you kissed Harry Potter I'm sorry I got
to sing a little sexy son as Lillian and
maybe even accidentally Kissin oh you
okay that's gotta be Daniel calling me
because you just can't leave me alone as
for how all that kimmy schmitt stars are
handling life in quarantine
yes Daniel's been reading Harry Potter
to fans Carol reunited with her former
taxi co-stars
but you're right I did think you were
the big big snob Ellie has an idea for
another office reunion I think for the
office I think it'd be great if we did
like a Christmas special just like again
like a one-off everybody comes together
and as for Jane I'm just eating way too
much you're like uh you know we're in
Corona you could let's we can have the
mini cupcake but I also have a minor
personal rule that you need to wear
clothes that hurt a little bit so you
stay your size and I completely
completely leaned into the sweat pad
thing
I don't even know how I'm gonna catch up
with this thing we after you have to go
back out and put on the pants with the
waistband because it isn't gonna work
[Music]